[Music]
what is going on guys this is
statistically challenged here and today
I've got a sick video for you guys I
finally killed 200 of these things after
they buffed them and I'm gonna tell you
that the loot still isn't that good but
it's better it's much better it took me
three Slayer tasks to finally kill 200
as you can see my inventory I've got the
bracelet of slaughter what this does is
when you wear it as you killed why burn
it has a one in four chance of not
counting as a kill count on your so
tasks so that extended it for quite a
bit I did miss it sometimes because I
was getting kind of lazy and I actually
died like three times here because few
afk as you can see these wyverns do hit
[__] hard these are pretty hard to
kill I mean I wasn't max gear pretty
much except for the infernal cake and on
task and I was still only getting eight
kills a trip which is pretty [__] I mean
further drops when we get to the loot
tab you'll see what I mean
I'm just trying to talk about their like
average drop value when you compare this
to other Sega monsters that require
lower slayer such as skeletal Librans or
gargoyles these things tend to actually
drop pretty [__] drops for the amount of
time it does take to kill them and we're
gonna see that in just a few seconds
alright guys so after killing 200 of the
new buffs agent wyverns we've come up
with a loop tab and I know a lot of you
guys want to see this to see if it's
work worth killing them so let's go
directly into the bank and oh yeah
before I show you the tab I just wanted
to show you the log on the Slayer home
as you can see check when I go to the
log
it'll show that I've killed 282 fossil
island Librans keep in mind that I
killed 50 of the old ancient islands and
I killed like thirty of the other
drivers but in this one's happier when
you see two hundred of the new ancient
why birds killed so as we can see this
is the loot tab the 52 mil cache is
actually from the wide envisage I got on
killcount I believe it was 16 I used to
pineapple pizzas as food super strength
potions to hit harder obviously and
enchanted ruby necklaces or Jake's eye
pendants so that trips could be faster
as you can see I got two rare fossils
seven small and too large we managed to
get quite a few we pretty much managed
to hit all video drop table items except
for the granite boots and the granite
longswords which I'm not too upset about
because those are complete [__] items
and they're worth nothing see I'm going
to take all this stuff out and price
check it to see if it is even worth
going back and doing these tasks okay so
I'm guessing most of the money is gonna
come from those Onyx Bowl tips yep I was
right and the vibrant bones as you guys
can see the price checker this all sums
up to three mil for 200 kills we only
got three mil I was really hoping it's
gonna be more that's not including the
visage of course but with the busy
I got fifty five point five mil this
took around I would say took around five
to six hours probably yeah probably five
to six hours took a while keep it mind
it'ly times we're gonna sell everything
off but three mil isn't worth killing
them i would have to go with a note this
only means that every single kill you
were getting an average loot of fifteen
thousand gold approximately that's like
basically a much widens give you just
skeletal libraries I don't know why
these are such a high slavery
requirement so hard to kill
they literally burn all your food every
kill
and they only give you this much prouder
like some of the drops are displayed
only worse like they drop like six
battle stabs instead of ten which dealt
saliva drop like why would they drop
less it just make any sense
these are not worth killing I would not
recommend going to fuss line to kill
these go do other [__] on fossil Island
I hope you guys enjoyed this video
I'm fine never gonna kill these again
cuz da [__] pile see until next time